Traduttore: Lucia Simonte
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Avete mai rivolto il vostro sguardo
verso il cielo,
verso le stelle, il buio profondo
oppure verso il sole e le nuvole
chiedendovi che cosa ci sia
al di là del nostro pianeta?
Domande come questa mi hanno
sempre affascinata fin da bambina
e mi hanno spinta,
sebbene il mio percorso di studi
non sia sempre stato di tipo scientifico,
dato che ho un diploma linguistico
e una laurea in clarinetto
mi hanno spinta verso
l'ingegneria aerospaziale
me ne hanno fatto innamorare
e quindi l'ho poi scelta
come percorso di studi.
Questo amore per lo spazio,
è arrivato in particolar modo
al termine delle scuole superiori,
in quel momento della vita di una persona
in cui si deve scegliere
che cosa fare del proprio futuro.
E assieme ad essa
è arrivata la consapevolezza
di voler dedicare la mia vita a qualcosa
di particolare, di affascinante,
in grado di mettermi alla prova
e di far emergere le mie capacità.
Già al termine della laurea triennale,
sono riuscita ad entrare
a far parte di un progetto
che ha dato una svolta
importantissima alla mia vita:
ovvero Star.
Assieme ad altri quattro studenti
dell'Università di Padova
siamo infatti riusciti
ad ideare un meccanismo
per lo svolgimento del riavvolgimento
di un filo nello spazio.
E questo meccanismo
ha numerosissime applicazioni.
Ne vediamo però assieme una,
forse la più affascinante
e la più urgente,
che è il problema dei detriti spaziali.
La ricerca in campo spaziale
ha portato negli anni
a delle conseguenze
che sono spesso state ignorate,
ma per le quali la nostra generazione
rischia di dover pagare un prezzo
decisamente molto alto.
Non tutti sanno che
sopra le nostre teste
orbita una quantità
elevatissima di oggetti.
Parliamo di serbatoi per il propellente
vuoti, di satelliti non più funzionanti,
di componenti minori.
Per tradurre il tutto con un'immagine,
comune e attuale,
si è passati in pochi anni ad avere
un disabitato e idilliaco
paesaggio naturale
a una vera e propria metropoli di detriti.
Introducendo qualche numero,
parliamo di circa 18.000 oggetti
di dimensioni rilevanti,
di circa 750.000 oggetti
di dimensioni medie,
circa quelle di una moneta,
e di milioni di oggetti
inferiori ad un centimetro.
Il vero problema è che solo
il 6 - 7 per cento di essi è funzionante,
quindi 1.100 satelliti circa.
Il restante 94 per cento
è costituito da materiale che nel corso
degli anni è stato accumulato nello spazio
e che ora vaga incontrollato.
Quindi potete ben capire
quanto sia rischioso
impattare contro uno di essi,
e questo rappresenta un problema
decisamente importante
per le missioni attuali,
ma anche per quelle future.
Ora immaginate di aver
n mano una nocciolina,
che è più o meno la dimensione
di un detrito medio,
e di poterla lanciare
contro un altro oggetto
ad una velocità di 35.000,
40.000 chilometri orari,
una cosa di tutti i giorni insomma.
L'effetto contro quest'altro oggetto
sarebbe equiparabile
non a quello di un incidente stradale
o di uno sparo di un proiettile,
ma a quello di una granata.
Lascio quindi alla vostra immaginazione
a cosa potrebbe portare l'impatto contro
un detrito delle dimensioni di un camion.
Quindi, con questa immagine
ben chiara in testa,
potete capire bene la gravità
del problema dei detriti spaziali.
Che cosa fare quindi
di fronte ad un problema
di coinvolgimento globale di questo tipo?
Già da alcuni anni la NASA,
l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
e la Comunità Internazionale
hanno adottato
delle norme, delle procedure
per poter limitare
il problema dei detriti,
però queste non sono sufficienti.
Non sono sufficienti senza
la rimozione attiva dei detriti
e quindi parliamo
dell'intervento dell'uomo.
Il vero problema è come fare
questa rimozione attiva.
Infatti ogni meccanismo deve avere
delle caratteristiche particolari:
deve essere tecnologicamente costruibile,
economicamente appetibile
e cosa più importante deve essere
un buon compromesso
dal punto di vista politico
a livello internazionale.
Superate queste tre prove,
queste tre caratteristiche
non deve costituire un rischio
per la popolazione a terra.
Quindi, capite bene quanto sia complesso
da affrontare questo problema.
Nonostante questo, sono state proposte
diverse soluzioni negli anni
e parliamo ad esempio di reti o di vele
ma anche soluzioni un po' più esotiche.
In questo contesto,
si inserisce il progetto
di cui faccio parte, quindi STAR,
che è stato ideato da cinque studenti
dell'università di Padova
che potete vedere alle mie spalle
e che ora vi presento.
A partire dalla vostra sinistra
trovate Leonardo Pellegrina,
poi ci sono Mattia Pezzato, al centro
il nostro Team Leader Gilberto Grassi,
quindi Alvise Rossi e poi io.
Come accennato, STAR è un meccanismo
per lo srotolamento e l'avvolgimento
di un filo nello spazio.
Questo meccanismo va poi inserito
all'interno di un satellite più grande,
chiamato satellite madre,
che grazie a questo filo
può andare ad agganciare
questo detrito od oggetto
per poi riportarlo a terra
oppure lanciarlo, diciamo,
verso l'infinito ed oltre.
La nostra esperienza è iniziata nel 2015
quando il professore di impianti
e sistemi aerospaziali di Padova,
Alessandro Francesconi,
ci ha suggerito di provare
uno di quei bandi
che ogni anno l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
mette a disposizione
per gli studenti universitari
per avvicinarli già dai primi anni
alla ricerca in campo spaziale;
quindi, potete immaginare il nostro
entusiasmo di fronte a questa proposta.
E quindi, era nata anche la voglia
di mettersi poi in gioco
e di contribuire alla ricerca spaziale.
Dopo circa un anno di studi
e anche qualche fallimento,
nel 2016 abbiamo avuto
la straordinaria notizia
di esser stati selezionati
proprio per uno di questi bandi,
il bando " Drop Your Thesis",
che permette di testare il proprio
esperimento nella torre di caduta di Brema
che vedete alle mie spalle,
e che è una delle strutture
che si ha sulla terra
per simulare la condizione
di assenza di peso dello spazio.
Come vedete, si tratta di un enorme torre
che viene svuotata dell'aria,
all'interno della quale viene lanciata una
capsula contenente l'esperimento
con due modalità:
c'è una prima modalità, la modalità Drop,
con cui viene lasciata cadere
la capsula dall'alto,
con cui si sperimentano
circa 4,7 secondi di assenza di peso
o la modalità Catapulta,
che è quella di cui ha usufruito STAR,
e che, invece, da accesso
a 9,3 secondi di assenza di peso.
Tornando alla nostra esperienza,
noi al momento della selezione, ovviamente
dopo un periodo di totale euforia,
ci siamo resi conto
di aver pochissimo tempo
per portare quella che nel momento
della selezione era un'idea geniale,
ma completamente astratta,
a qualcosa poi di concreto.
Come previsto dal programma,
infatti, avevamo circa sette mesi,
da marzo ad ottobre,
per passare dalla fase idea,
alla fase poi di test.
La nostra poca esperienza nel campo
della ricerca però non era certo d'aiuto.
Noi infatti stavamo proponendo qualcosa di
estremamente innovativo e nuovo,
e quindi non c'erano
dei libri su cui studiare
o delle missioni passate
a cui appoggiarsi al 100 per cento.
Grazie però all'input iniziale
del nostro professore, dei suoi dottorandi
e dell'ingegnere Riccardo Mantellato,
siamo riusciti a sviluppare le prime idee
e ad arrivare in poco tempo
ad un concetto finale.
Per la progettazione ci siamo ispirati
ad un meccanismo 'sconosciutissimo':
la canna da pesca.
E l'abbiamo poi adattata allo spazio;
cosa che magari, ad una prima impressione,
può sembrare un po' banale,
ma in realtà quello che il nostro team
si è trovato ad affrontare
è stata una vera e propria sfida
nei confronti di anni di studio.
In effetti, nel passato tutto le missioni
che hanno utilizzato dei fili
avevano dei meccanismi
enormi e molto pesanti
nei quali il filo spesso
si inceppava o si tranciava
quindi portando poi
al fallimento della missione.
La nostra bravura invece
è stata proprio quella di adottare
un meccanismo semplice
e leggero allo spazio.
Non abbiamo mai smesso di credere
di poterlo realizzare nonostante tutto,
cosa che ci ha aiutato nei sette mesi,
dato che comunque,
le difficoltà che abbiamo affrontato
sono state decisamente numerose.
Parliamo, ad esempio, di soluzioni
che poi si sono rivelate non vincenti,
oppure di ordini
che hanno tardato ad arrivare,
o scarsa collaborazione
con aziende, con terze persone,
e fondi, in realtà, che in un primo
momento erano quasi inesistenti
e che ci hanno a volte
addirittura impedito
di comprare la componentistica necessaria.
In qualche modo però siamo riusciti
ad adattarci alla situazione,
quindi trovando delle soluzioni
alternative, meno costose
e, in un primo momento,
quasi autofinanziandoci.
Alla fine di settembre però,
il nostro esperimento
andava costruito in qualche modo
e alla fine ce l'abbiamo fatta,
con decisamente molti caffè in corpo
e anche qualche notte un pò insonne.
Però, alla fine di settembre
il nostro esperimento era concreto,
era lì davanti a noi.
Quindi, siamo poi volati a Brema
per due delle settimane
che forse sono tra le settimane
più indimenticabili della nostra vita.
Durante la prima settimana
abbiamo avuto modo di confrontarci
con i tecnici e gli esperti
della torre di caduta
che ci hanno dato tantissimi consigli.
È stata una settimana
veramente molto educativa
durante la quale abbiamo apportato
le ultime migliorie al nostro esperimento
e l'abbiamo poi inserito
all'interno della capsula che vedete.
Al termine della prima settimana,
quindi il nostro esperimento era pronto
per quello che poi sarebbe stato
il vero cuore del nostro progetto,
quindi la settimana dei lanci,
che erano in tutto cinque, uno al giorno.
Questa settimana, il giorno tipo
prevedeva la sveglia presto,
una controllata generale dell'esperimento
e quindi magari la sostituzione
di qualche componente
poi vi era l'inserimento
all'interno della torre e il lancio.
Al termine del lancio, veniva poi
nuovamente inserita l'aria
all'interno della torre,
veniva recuperata la capsula
e in serata c'era quindi
l'analisi del comportamento
ed eventuali modifiche
per il lancio successivo.
Ora, immaginate di condensare sette mesi
di lavoro, di fatiche, di sogni
e a volte anche un po' di disperazione,
di speranze, in nove secondi
e potrete avvicinarvi
a quella che era la nostra sensazione
all'inizio di questa seconda settimana.
Quel bottone rosso ormai andava premuto,
e dare il via quindi
alla sequenza di lancio
che avrebbe svelato se quei sette mesi
poi avrebbero portato a dei frutti.
Qui eravamo all'interno
della torre di controllo.
Come avete potuto vedere in questo video
(Applausi)
Grazie
Come avete potuto vedere in questo video,
siamo orgogliosi di dire che il nostro
esperimento ha avuto successo
in tutti e cinque i lanci,
ed è un risultato che ha superato
anche le più rosee delle aspettative
e ha lasciato spazio a diversi
progetti per il nostro futuro.
In effetti, abbiamo da poco depositato
il brevetto del nostro meccanismo.
C'è spazio per nuovi studi
e approfondimenti,
e ci saranno poi delle pubblicazioni
e stiamo anche raccogliendo dei fondi
per partecipare a delle conferenze
nazionali ed internazionali
per i quali ci hanno già selezionati.
A conclusione di tutto,
ci tengo a sottolineare
quanto ognuno di noi abbia speso
energie e sogni per questo progetto
sacrificando tantissime ore
di lavoro e di studio
e di divertimento,
cosa che non tutti i ventitreenni
al giorno d'oggi sono disposti a fare.
Siamo partiti da un'idea completamente
astratta, su un foglio, senza fondi,
senza conoscere veramente nel dettaglio
l'oggetto di ciò che stavamo creando,
e senza conoscerci nemmeno
benissimo tra di noi,
per arrivare poi ad essere un team
unito e con un sogno comune
e quindi siamo fieri di aver dimostrato
che con l'impegno,
la determinazione e la passione,
i risultati prima o poi arrivino.
Noi non sappiamo se il nostro meccanismo
verrà mai considerato da qualche
agenzia spaziale o se volerà.
La cosa importante però è che ognuno
di noi ha cercato e sta tuttora cercando
di scrivere un piccolo
pezzettino di storia,
e, chi lo sa, magari in un futuro
non troppo lontano potremmo dire
di aver contribuito a far ritornare
lo spazio un posto libero e incontaminato
come tutti noi ce lo immaginiamo.
(Applausi)